You're a victim. You're just a pass by.
I'm a victim.
>> What's up, man? God bless you, bro.
>> God bless you, man. Let them take you
away, man. Let them take you away from
this pot.
>> It's okay, bro.
>> Okay. Heavy metals come from
>> the bottom of the earth when we have
>> How did the earth form?
>> What?
>> You ask me scientific. Scientifically,
what does the science say? Where does he
met?
>> They come from space. They come from the
cores of asteroids and stars.
>> Talking about iron.
>> Yes. Heavy [music] metals, right?
>> Well, specifically iron. Like
>> iron specifically and other heavy
metals.
>> The the Egyptians, they they they had
that information like thousands of years
before. Yes, they did.
>> Uh, brother, can you um Yeah. Can I get
your phone real quick? I'm going show
you.
>> The the Egyptians, they are the ones who
uh like we see in the earlier sources of
where they had this idea that iron came
from the heavens. It came from the sky.
Okay.
>> Okay. Um, yeah. It's a It's a long time
before Muhammad.
>> Listen, if you talk to any Muslim, we
believe that Islam predates the Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him.
>> So, where do you think it started? Do
you think it started in Egypt?
>> Okay. So, you guys clearly don't have
knowledge, do you?
>> What do you mean?
>> You're making Yeah, you're making the
You're making the claim.
>> If you you're you're sitting out here,
you want to talk to Muslims and other
people about their own religion.
>> Yes. But then you don't have your own
knowledge of like what do Muslims
actually believe in you know my friend
what you're doing is making a claim but
you're not providing any evidence.
>> I can't tell you what you guys believe
is not exist in the Quran. You guys
believe I have a belief you are having
the you are trying to tell me oh I can
prove that what you believe in isn't
true.
>> The burden of proof comes to you. So it
says, "Yes, ancient Egyptians believed
in iron
>> came from the sky, calling it bea in I
don't know how to pronounce it, but or
iron from the sky, using it for valuable
ritual objects like King Tut's dagger
because they understood it came from
meteorites and so on and so forth." So
yeah, Egyptians had this knowledge about
iron coming from rocks from the sky and
stuff like that. So So this wouldn't be
divine revelation uh Muhammad, you know,
having in the Quran. This was something
people knew knew already.
>> The listen what Muslims believe in is
that
>> the message of Islam
comes in the same way as it did in the
Bible which is why
>> the message in the Old Testament is that
God created Adam and Eve. Correct?
>> He had the uh Adam we call we call him
Adam you know he was given
commands by God. Correct.
Yes.
>> Right. [music]
>> So we believe that the original message
of God, the worship of God started from
the first person which was Adam.
>> I I understand that but like correct.
>> But to to this point that's that's yeah
that's something that we have that's
that's something that we have in common.
But the point that I was I wanted us to
to hinge on is that you brought this
idea of the Quran mentioning how iron
comes like Allah sent down iron, right?
As if that was miraculous information.
Would you say then
>> scientific evidence?
>> Okay. So would you say then that the
Egyptians they had some prophet there or
they had some really so who was the
prophet of of Egypt?
>> God sent Moses to Egypt and many other
prophets but but they
>> we believe in the Quran that God sent
over thousands and thousands of prophets
to all the corners of the world.
>> So you believe that Moses is the prophet
that was in Egypt that
>> he was one of the prophets in Egypt.
Yeah.
>> Okay. So, so this is where like it's
getting confusing for me because the
Quran says that all that we do not send
a messenger to a nation except in the na
in the language of their own of his own
people. Right. The Egyptians were not
the people of Moses. The Jews were the
Hebrews. Right.
>> Right. But Moses as a baby, he grew up
in Egypt.
>> Yeah. But he's not of he's not an
Egyptian.
>> Yeah. But he spoke their language.
>> Well, no. No. So, if you're talking
about Moses being a of the people of his
nation, he only sends a a messenger to
the people of his nation. Egypt is not
his nation.
>> There would have to be a prophet in
Egypt that God is revealing things to
that is getting his revelation.
>> God had many prophets that were in
Egypt.
>> Like who?
>> Like for example, we believe that Ysef,
which is Joseph,
>> but Jo Joseph didn't originate. He's not
an Egyptian. He's a Hebrew.
>> That's not the point. You speak English
and you're not originally an English.
>> I'm an American,
>> right? Yes.
>> No, but Okay. But the language you speak
comes from where?
>> It comes from here. America.
>> From England. English comes from.
>> But I'm I'm an American.
>> You know what I'm saying? This is my
This is my people.
>> Okay. The point that you're saying is
that God only sent prophets to the
nation and the language that they speak.
But if you are you were born in America,
you were raised in America. You speak
the English language in an American
dialect, right? How is that any
different than than Moses growing up in
Egypt and speaking their language as
well? So the difference is is that the
Quran says that the pe that the
messenger is sent to he sent to his own
people. That's that's the and the people
who speak his language of his tongue.
That that's the point. The point is is
that if you're saying that there's many
messengers of of you know sent to Egypt
which is no problem with that. But what
the Quran saying it's it gives a
specific requirement like Joseph for
example Joseph was an Egyptian.
>> There isn't a specific requirement. Jo
like for how did Joseph even get to
Egypt? Listen,
>> he was a slave.
>> Listen, listen. You believe in the same
many of the same prophets that I do.
Correct.
>> You're dodging the question, brother.
>> No, no, no. Cuz Okay, but our We have to
look at the conversation as a whole,
right?
>> Okay.
>> Right. You're trying to ask these
specific questions with these arbitrary.
>> They're not arbitrary.
>> They are arbitrary cuz what you're
saying is just not true.
>> What What did I What did I say that
wasn't true? Listen, the point is
is that we have the same we believe in
the same prophets that were sent to the
same people. Same story. [music]
>> We don't.
>> What do you mean?
>> Okay.
>> You don't believe in Moses.
>> No. So what what what I'm what I'm
saying is is that you don't you when you
say that you believe in the prophets,
>> do you believe like
>> for example, can I say I believe in
Muhammad but reject what he says?
>> Wonderful. Like can I say I I can I say
I believe in Muhammad but I reject him
as a prophet. I reject his Quran.
>> Okay. That's your that's your belief.
Sure.
>> Yeah. But can I say that I rightly
believe in Muhammad?
>> Believe in what? That he existed?
>> No. Not that he No, not that he exist
but believing in what? Like would you
agree that to believe in something to
believe in someone mean that you agree
with him?
>> Told me right now he believe in
Muhammad.
>> So he believe in Muhammad but he didn't
believe in him. Mahal
>> if you are rejecting everything that he
says.
>> Exactly. So I So exactly so I can come
to you and say I believe in Muhammad but
if I'm rejecting everything he says I
don't truly believe in him. And and so
it's the same what is the point?
>> The point is is that when you say that
you believe in the same prophets we do,
right? You believe that Moses is a
prophet and all these other prophets. My
point is is that you reject what they
say. They're saying you reject what they
say. See what they're saying is corrupt.
>> How do you reject what they say? Yeah.
So, cuz if I were to open to you the
Torah right now and show you what Moses
taught, you would reject it because
you'll see that it contradicts what
Muhammad taught. The
>> Torah is not a quote of Moses.
>> Who who taught the Torah, brother?
>> Huh?
>> Who taught the Torah?
>> So, the whole Old Testament are not
quotes from the prophet.
>> I'm talking about the Torah
specifically.
>> What about it?
>> Who who was the who was the one who was
reciting the Torah?
>> Copy of the Torah.
>> That's not what I asked. Please answer.
>> Okay. Well, if you don't have it, how
are you supposed to
>> notice? Notice how you're not dealing
with Stay focused in the conversation.
Who was the one who was revealing the
Torah?
>> Okay. Do you have
>> Do you see how you're dodging the
question?
>> Listen,
>> like for example, Muhammad was the one
reciting the Quran. You would agree that
Jesus is the one that was reciting the
gospel, right?
>> Right.
>> The original.
>> Okay. And who and who and who was and
who was reciting the original Torah?
>> Right.
>> Moses, right?
>> Okay.
>> Okay. If I showed you what Moses was
saying, what he taught, you can't you
don't have.
>> Ah, and see here it is. You're rejecting
that we have what you're rejecting that
what we have is the Torah when the Quran
says it is the Torah.
>> No, it doesn't say that.
>> We got a Quran, right?
>> All right. Go. I'm going to show you
something. Watch this. It It quotes from
my Torah that I have. Let me show you.
Go to chapter 5 verse 45.
>> Yeah. Show you. I'm going
>> 545.
>> Oh, both. Oh, you speak Arabic.
>> Yes. Yes. Oh, this is awesome.
>> Okay. 5:45.
>> Do we have a Bible?
>> A Bible?
>> Yeah. Do we have a physical Bible?
Okay, this is correct. All right, you
see that? So, so do you, so do you see
it? It said eye for an eye, uh, life for
life, two for it, not please, please
chill. So, you see how it gave you that
quote, right? It said that we ordained
therein, right? So, in the Torah, this
is what we, this is what is in there.
Just this one.
>> Now, let me show you. I'm going to show
you that it's quoting from my Torah.
It's quoting from what we have today.
So, if we go to the Torah, specifically
the book of Exodus. Okay. This is the
second book of the Torah.
>> Okay.
>> We go to Exodus chapter 21.
>> Okay. It's reminding that
>> Chill, bro. Chill. Chill. It's okay.
It's all right. Relax.
>> Exodus 21 23 2.
>> That's okay.
>> Yeah. Um All right. So, Exodus 21 23 2
>> 23. Yeah, exactly, brother. This is
small, so my bad. But look what this
what it says. Um verse 23 it says uh all
right but if any man harms if any harm
follows then he shall give life for life
okay
>> eye for eye tooth for tooth hand for
hand foot for foot burn for burn wound
for wound stripe for stripe
>> right so notice the Quran says this is
what you'll find in the Torah
>> when I open the Torah that's exactly
what I find so the Quran says that we it
it says that it's not not only is it
quoting the Torah that I have it says
it's true it says says it's revealed by
God. So for you for you for you to say
that we don't have the Torah of the
Quran, that's false. Trying to say that
because there's one verse
of that is a reference to another verse
doesn't mean that now the whole book is
now
>> Yeah. Correct. Exactly.
>> Very good point.
>> Show him chapter 2 verse 85.
>> Okay. You can like none of what you're
saying is proving anything. You know
>> what? What what did I what did what I
say not prove? You're trying to suggest
that the complete Torah
>> Mhm.
>> is an uncorrupted original.
>> That's according to the Quran. Yeah. It
says in Revelation. Okay. Watch it.
Watch this. 285. This is 285.
>> Now, now remember the point. I'm going
to show you why I'm bringing you this
verse.
>> All of this doesn't answer what you're
>> Oh, it's answering where we're at in the
conversation. This is where we're at. So
notice what you're saying is just
because the Quran is saying that one
part of the Torah is true doesn't mean
that all of it is true. Right? So I'm
going to show you how the Quran
completely disagrees with this point of
view. You're not the only one that has
it. That some part of the scripture is
true while other parts are false or
corrupted. Okay? I'm going to show you
that the Quran says whoever thinks like
that is going to go to hell. Okay? So
this is chapter 2. Suraka verse 85. Go
ahead. It's not now.
Here
it comes.
So, so do you see how it said that book
if you reject do you believe in part of
the book and reject other scripture
other part?
>> Do you know what the context of?
>> Oh, there's a bunch of things in it.
It's about the Israelites about the a
bunch of stories within Israel.
>> Right. But do you know what does Bakar
mean?
>> Cow. Okay.
>> But that's that has nothing to do with
the issue. The Quran says you can't pick
and choose verse the time of Moses. You
can't pick and choose. This he's talking
to the followers of Moses telling his
people you cannot pick one part of my
message and not the others.
>> Exactly. So why are you doing that? Why
are you doing that? Because Exactly.
>> No, this is in the time of Muhammad.
This is Oh, so wait, hold on.
>> The Quran has many chapters,
>> right? So who who is the Quran? So who
is the Quran?
>> Can you pick a verse of You're
absolutely right. Where where in the who
is the Quran talking to? That's it. Can
we please go?
>> Yeah, I know.
>> This is important to say
>> this or listen to you.
>> This is a This is the We're having a
good conversation. He's learning videos
of you from
this. This is knowledge. This is for
everyone to learn
from here.
We posted photos of this guy on the
>> That's right. We sure did. He's running
from us. He's a coward. Yes. But this
this guy has enough courage to actually
have the conversation.
>> He's more brave than Oman. of mine is
joining. He's standing and talking.
>> Yes. I don't care.
>> But why are we going to do it to you
next?
>> Huh? Why? [laughter] Because he posts he
posts pictures and videos of our brother
over here and lying about Christianity.
That's why people, you know, if he
wasn't like that, we would not have done
that.
>> I'm just I'm just saying that the Quran
has
>> It's very Christian of us. Yes. It's
very Christian. We We handle We handle
people
love Muslims. Then you'll expose.
>> Yeah. We We expose Islam. Yes. It is
Jesus. Jesus said to expose the liar.
>> So it's fine for you guys as a Muslim to
lie but not fine for us to show you
really.
>> What do you mean? What do you mean act
like you? No. No. No. No. No. No. Notice
notice what you're notice. Notice how
you're talking. Look, sister. Let's You
see what you're doing? Nobody. Who said
we're better than Muslims?
>> Who said we're better than Muslims?
>> That's like prove that it came.
Sister, notice how this has nothing to
do with Muslim people, but the religion
and the idea. We're discussing ideas and
the religion. Did we ever Wait, hold on
a second. Hold on a second. You're being
a little bit too Yes. If they're lying,
yes. Would you agree? Yes. Jesus said,
"Expose the liar." Jesus said, "Expose
the expose falsehood." That's what he
said. Yes.
>> Wouldn't you agree?
>> So, you don't you think that we should
let lies just go? in the ground.
>> Forgiving is different from letting a
lie spread.
>> Did Jesus cut off lies though? Did he
teach the truth?
>> The reason that for example
>> I agree. So when people
when when when the people when the
people lied when people lied, what did
Jesus do?
>> Wait, hold on. When people when people
lied, what did Jesus do?
>> Scissor answer. You don't got to speak
out of emotion. Can you please
>> I bet you're too It's a little
emotional. You got to
give me this. Listen, I'm not
there are people who have doctorates and
this stuff. We're talking to you,
>> brother. They say the same things you're
saying. I'm trust me, you're not saying
anything different than what the guys
with with careers and and hadith and
everything. I'm not teaching a course
trying to tell you this is exactly where
this is shown and this is not but you're
making a claim and all we're asking you
to do is substantiate that claim like
you're raping that they're getting
content out of you. Let's go.
>> Wait, Tom. We're having a good
conversation conversation.
>> Thank you, brother.
>> Hang on a second. He's he's saying he's
saying so my friend. So when the Quran
is telling you to that that to not
cherry pick from your
cherryicking
>> that's what it is. That's what you're
doing when you're saying the parts of
the scriptures are true. You can't share
it.
>> You're okay. I'm telling you what
Muslims believe.
>> So now you're telling me prove it like
>> Yes. So look look this is important.
This is important.
>> Muslims believe that message from
we know what Muslims believe.
>> It does not it doesn't go with the
Quran. That's why we're here is because
>> your belief doesn't match the Quran.
That's the point. The reason we're
hearing the Quran, they didn't tell you
the Bible corrupted or the Torah
corrupted.
>> They cherrypicked the Bible.
>> So you cannot
>> Exactly. They cherrypicked the Bible and
they cherrypicked the Quran. They
chericed both.
>> Listen, it's not cherry.
>> Do you respect your Quran?
>> Of course I respect.
>> Do you respect Do you believe what is
written in it?
>> I do.
>> So when the when the Quran saying the
Torah is good, don't part of it and
leave part of it. You don't respect the
word of Allah. It doesn't say that the
message that we say that these books
were perfect and and these prophets were
>> give them to 89.
>> Yeah. Actually,
>> you wouldn't have sent other prophets.
>> That's not true.
>> This book even about all about Muhammad.
>> Wait, so just really quick, just really
quick. Remember when when you know how
the Quran says that Jesus came after
Moses confirming the Torah?
>> So Jesus didn't come because the Torah
was messed up. He came confirming the
Torah that was with him. So, so
according So, according to the Quran,
Jesus came even when the Torah was still
intact and good. 543. Uh, yeah, give him
543. Watch this. Is this is in
Muhammad's time. Watch this. This is
Muhammad time when Allah even Allah
telling to Muhammad. Okay the Torah is
more upholding over Muhammad because
here in saying
so how come they make you judgement to
among them? Oh Muhammad how come the
Jews make you judge among them and they
have the Torah they have a God judgment
in it.
>> They have it the laws are correct they
can judge corrupted. So even in
Muhammad's time, Allah is saying that
the Torah is still good and has Allah's
judgment in it.
>> Not all of Torah.
>> It just said, why do they come to you
for judgment when they have the Torah in
which Allah's judgment is in?
>> The laws are correct. They can judge the
corrupted.
>> So if the Torah is still good for
judgment, so is Allah saying that you
can judge from a corrupted book?
>> There are no claims in the Quran that
the Torah or the Injil have not been
corrupted.
>> You're looking you're looking at it
right here. The Quran says it confirms
it.
>> It's not saying that the entire Torah is
not
>> Look, okay, look. This is what we need,
brother. What we need is this. Okay, I
gave you an explicit verse where Allah
says, wait, let me finish so you hear me
out. I repeat all of your I gave you I
gave you an explicit verse where Allah
says that you're not allowed to to
believe in part of the scripture and
reject other parts of the scripture.
Moses, I also g we also gave you a verse
that Hold on. Listen, let me land.
Please let me land.
>> No, because this whole thing Not letting
me, brother. Let me get this out. This
is important. I'm going to listen to you
that you're saying.
>> I'm going to listen to you. I I get you.
Tell me how it's going to correct when I
finish. Okay. Trust me. No, no, I'm not.
I'm I'm laying it out for you.
>> You're not laying out.
>> So, okay. So, you're getting them
frustrated. I understand. But if the
Quran says one thing, says you're not
allowed to believe in part of the
scripture and reject other parts of the
scripture and then the the scripture
also says that you uh that
>> that why do they come to you for
judgment when they have the Torah in
which Allah's judgement is in? So Allah
is already saying that the Torah they
have is true.
It's not what we're saying. Okay. So one
more one more. No, not one more verse.
Go to chapter uh stay in chapter 2. Mhm.
>> Stay in chapter 2. Go to 41.
>> Chapter 241.
>> Watch. I'm going to show you and then
you're going to have to give me what
you're saying.
>> Many parts of the Quran are not
referring to the Prophet Muhammad
himself.
>> It's literally referring to Muhammad.
>> It's not. See that? See right there?
That's how you know that your
understanding of the Quran is incorrect.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> You still haven't shown me how there are
plenty of stories. You haven't brought
any given stories
>> that are completely
>> not related to the prophet.
>> I agree. Okay. For example, you're
taking a verse out of context and you're
saying that, oh, this was given to the
prophets.
>> How am I taking a verse? You haven't
demonstrated I'm taking a verse out of
context. You're just saying it.
>> Your whole your whole assumption here
>> is
>> that all of these verses are commands
from God to the prophet. That's not what
they are.
>> No, no, I I agree. Some of Some of these
are commands to the people of the Wait,
hold on. Some of these are commands.
Notice how you're cutting me off when
you just finished, bro.
>> Cuz I wasn't done.
>> But you just took a long pause. You made
a point. Let me respond to what you just
said.
>> I don't I don't have time. Oh, you don't
have time for a conversation,
>> bro. I've been sitting here and you're
just repeating the same thing over and
over.
>> Oh, so so all right without you actually
bringing a single verse. You're saying
it's out of context. You're getting
angry because you can't quote the Quran.
>> I'm giving you the Quran. You can't give
me Quran. That's what that's where we're
at.
>> Okay.
>> So, look, here's this one last verse and
then you could do what you want.
What does what does what does mean?
Okay. So, does it say believe in what
I've revealed to you, confirming what is
with you? Does it say that?
>> With them at the time of Moses, please.
>> Does it say what's with you? Right.
>> Nonsense.
>> Be honest. Does it say it's confirming
what's with them?
>> What was at the time of Moses?
>> The context is that Allah is telling the
Jews to believe in the Quran because it
agrees with what they have.
>> What was the context?
>> So, do you agree with the Jews?
>> The Torah, the Torah, the Gospel, the
scriptures. God is not telling the Jews
to believe in the Quran in this verse.
>> What is he telling them to believe in?
What what when he says when he says
believe in what I reveal? What is that?
>> Listen. Listen. If there is a story,
>> no brother, answer that question.
>> Okay, let me answer you. There's a story
in the Quran talking about the times of
the prophet Moses and is telling you
that hey Moses is telling his people
believe in what I have brought down to
you. Right? Like he said he that is the
prophet Moses telling his people you
need to believe in what I have receive.
>> This isn't talking to Moses and in
Moses's time.
>> Talking to Muhammad believe in
>> talking to the Jews in Muhammad's time
to believe in the Quran. Bro
the time of Moses.
>> You want to go 33.
>> Does it say what they have with them?
Say that. Does it say that what was with
them?
>> What's with them? What was with them?
>> The word.
>> No, it says what is with them. Thank
you. So the Quran is saying that what's
with them is true, right? What was at
the time of
>> No, it doesn't say what was. It says
confirming what is with you, not what
was.
>> Show me the word is.
>> Show me.
>> What does word mean?
>> Exactly. So shut up. Get out of here.
Get out of here. You're done. You're
done, bro. You sound stupid. You sound
stupid. You are stupid. You're ignorant.
I repeat all of you.
>> So notice this. So everything that we've
seen, everything we've seen, we're
giving you Quran verses to show what we
believe. You haven't been able to give
us a Quran verse saying what you're
saying. That's the difference with us.
>> COULD THEY SHOW US WHAT YOU BELIEVE?
>> The difference is that you sit here all
day and you want to cherry pick these
verses and you prepared all of these
scripted things to go by. I'm a guy just
walking here traveling from another
state. Okay? So, of course, I'm not
going to sit here and have these verses
in my head just to be like, "Oh, go to
this page and this chapter and this
here." That's not the point of this. I'm
just a passer by. This isn't like a
presentation we prepared here to come
speak to each other about. And then to
be like, "Oh, I've one uped you now."
Okay. Did I ever say that I oneuped you?
>> Yeah. You're like, "Oh, we've given you
all these verses. You haven't given a
verse."
>> But I didn't say I one up you. Not
Notice. Okay. So, let me expl Let me
explain myself.
>> I'm a psychologist.
>> Yes. But let me let me go ahead and
explain myself.
>> I know what you're trying.
>> So, notice how you're cutting Notice how
you're talking over me.
>> See, here we go again.
>> Yes. So, with with this being said, if
you're saying you're trying to put it
into where I'm talk I'm one uping you.
You're the one running away from the
conversation, getting upset, getting
victim victim mode. This is what happens
with Muslims. Another victim.
>> Whenever you whenever you quote the
Quran of Muslims, they start crying.
Victimo, victimo, victim. Poor little
me.
You're a victim. You're just a passer.
>> What's up, man? God bless you, bro.
>> God bless you, man. Let them take you
away, man. Let them take you away from
this pot.
>> You don't have any ability to support
your opposition.
>> It's okay, bro.
>> You do want to talk.
>> No, no, no.
>> Oh, yeah. Then at the very end I found
that what you said disrespect
>> because trying to tell someone that the
religion that they believe in and their
like the beliefs that they have makes
them a victim.
>> No, that's not what we said.
See, you can't even you can't even get
us correct.
>> Said you I'm a victim for believing in
>> No, he said that what you're doing is
act is going into victim mode. Acting
like a victim in this conversation as if
you're being oppressed, as if you're
being talked over, as if you're being
bullied. No one is doing the only thing
that we've done to you. Notice notice
how you're cutting me off again.
>> So I can listen. So I've demonstrated to
you that I am willing to listen to you
even though you disagree with me and
you're talking about my character. I'm
still willing to hear you out. But
you're right. You say, "Yo, I'm a I'm a
psych I'm a psychologist. I know what
you're doing. You're trying to one up
me." That's not what this is. I'm having
a conversation with you. Okay? I'm
having a conversation with you. I'm
showing you what your Quran says. If you
disagree with what your Quran says, if
you disagree with what the Quran says,
then you have to show me in the Quran
why you disagree.
>> I have to show you anything.
>> Then therefore, you have no basis.
>> Listen, that's not my job.
>> You're a Muslim. It is your job.
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> Well, when you make when you make claims
and don't substantiate it with anything,
>> what claims?
>> You made the claims that the Bible is
corrupted. You made claims that the
Quran has miraculous uh uh divine
inspiration from Allah, revelation from
Allah. I believe I didn't make any
claims.
>> When you when you when you say what you
believe, you're making claims. That's
what it is.
>> I'm not saying I'm not telling you this.
This is
>> telling us what you believe is making a
claim, brother. Come on.
>> You should know better than what I
believe.
>> As simple as that.
>> That's what it's my belief.
>> Well, it's not telling you you should
believe this like you're trying to tell
me.
>> We never We never said you told us to do
that. You should believe in truth, bro.
You should You should believe in truth.
>> Right now, I believe in a pink elephant
in the sky flying. That's a claim for
me. So when I'm saying that to you, I
tell you I I believe there's a pink
elephant flying. That's a claim upon me.
So when when you're going to tell me,
okay, you said that to prove it. So
right now when we asked you, you said
the previous scripture, the Torah
corrupted, we show you multiple verses
from the Quran that the Quran actually
going against you now with you. And when
telling the Jews to share of their go to
is telling why they use you as a
judgment of Muhammad if the Torah is
good and there is a judgment in it is
coming confirming what with them at that
time. So you can tell with all these
verses we gave you my brother what we
saying we can show evidence upon the
Quran supporting our position but what
you saying unfortunately you don't have
any verse in the Quran
>> help you or like give you basis or
confirm or support you. So that with
that that's why we want you to go study
your own Quran with a skeptic mind not
just what you've been told by shakes and
imams because you know what they told
you is lies and they don't tell you the
truth because they want to take
advantage of you of your money of your
life that you know they use you as
vehicle for their own purposes so read
the Quran for yourself with open mind
open eyes say really saying the Quran
the the iron coming from the sky. So
it's really that's something scientific
the Quran they didn't have before.
>> So you need to do every you do your own
research because that's your life.
That's your afterlife. That's where
you're going to be end up in your
trinity. You're going to be believing
and you're going to be end up in hell or
heaven. That's all your your your
>> We just want you to have the truth, man,
and be open to it even if it it's if
it's uncomfortable.
That's our purpose.
>> Are you done?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Can we shake your hand?
>> Wait, what's his YouTube channel?
>> I didn't shake your hand.
>> My name's Avery, by the way. Bro,
what is that?
>> What's his YouTube channel?
>> God Logic Apologetics.
>> Marvin Thomas.
>> We're live streaming now.
>> Okay. What is it called?
>> God Logic.
>> And that's it.
>> Yep.
>> God bless you. God bless you guys. Have
a good day. [laughter]
>> Take care, man.
>> You can make it up. You guys see man,
when we deal with Islam, it gets real
uncomfortable when we start quoting the
Quran to Muslims. Real uncomfortable. He
started cussing, man. You're not showing
me and all that kind of stuff. A lot a
lot of a lot of issues come when you
show the Muslims what the Quran says
because they hate the Quran. They hate
the Quran, but they love their imams.
They love their shakes. They hate the
Quran though. You show them the Quran,
they're going to manifest. It's going to
come out. And that's exactly what we saw
from this seemingly nice guy. He then
got disrespectful, talking over us, not
wanting to hear what we're saying.
Didn't have a verse to back up what he's
saying. Got mad when we asked for a
verse. Started playing victim mode. This
is what happens with Islam. You say your
shahada, that's what you become. Just
letting y'all know before you join
Islam, just remember you're going to
have to take your brain out your head,
put it to the side, and just walk around
like a zombie and say, "Man, they're
bullying me." You know,
>> so
>> y'all reject the Quran, man.
>> Thanks, sweetheart. They hate the Quran.
>> They hate that book.
>> Contact them on TikTok.
>> THEY'RE JUST
>> Come on. You're doing that again, bro.
>> You have to go. You're doing that again.
Unfortunately for him, the Quran says to
speak with the people of the book in a
good manner, but he's saying don't speak
to the people of the book. So
unfortunately, [laughter]
unfortunately, they're getting annoyed
and unfortunately they're lying. They're
getting emotional and for some reason
they're getting the Quran says to speak
to the people of the book in a good
manner. Now, now [laughter] instead of
doing that, we got emotionalism,
we got victim mode, we got all of